Bromeábamos constantemente,
especialmente mis dos hermanos mayores.
Cuando perdí mi diente frontal,
mi hermano me miró y dijo:
"¿Te ha pasado a ti también?
Nunca volverá a crecer".
(Risas)
Disfruté jugando por todos lados,
especialmente en los jardines de mi madre y de mi vecino.
Me encantaba mi jardín de infancia.
Cantábamos canciones,
jugábamos por todos lados
y almorzábamos.
Tuve una infancia
que le desearía a cualquiera.
Pero cuando tenía seis años,
los adultos de mi familia comenzaron a hablar muy bajo
y a hacerme callar cada vez que yo hacía una pregunta.
Una noche,
vinieron mamá y papá.
Tenían esta extraña mirada cuando nos despertaban.
Nos enviaron a mi hermana mayor Claire y a mí
a casa de nuestros abuelos,
deseando que lo que estuviera ocurriendo desapareciera.
Pronto nos tuvimos que escapar de allí también.
Nos escondimos,
nos arrastramos,
a veces corrimos.
A veces oía risas,
y luego gritos y llantos
y luego ruidos que nunca había escuchado.
Ya ven,
yo no sabía
qué eran esos ruidos.
No eran humanos...
pero al mismo tiempo, eran humanos.
Vi personas que no respiraban.
Pensé que estaban dormidos.
Todavía no entendía lo que era la muerte,
o simplemente matar.
Cuando nos deteníamos para descansar un poco
o buscar comida,
cerraba los ojos,
esperando que al abrirlos,
despertaría.
No tenía ni idea de dónde estaba mi hogar.
Nos escondíamos de día
y caminábamos de noche.
Se pasa de una persona que está alejada de su hogar
a una persona sin hogar.
El lugar que se supone que le quiere
le ha empujado a salir,
y nadie le recibe.
No es querido
por nadie.
Es un refugiado.
De los 6 a los 12 años,
viví en siete países diferentes,
pasando de un campo de refugiados a otro,
deseando ser querida.
Mi hermana mayor, Claire,
fue madre joven...
y una maestra en terminar las cosas.
Cuando tenía 12 años,
vine a EE.UU. con Claire y su familia en estado de refugiado.
Y eso es solo el comienzo,
porque aunque tenía 12 años,
a veces sentía que tenía tres años
y algunas veces 50.
Mi pasado se esfumó,
se volvió confuso,
se distorsionó.
Todo era demasiado
y nada.
El tiempo parecía páginas arrancadas de un libro
esparcidas por todos lados.
Todavía me pasa incluso aquí.
Después de llegar a EE.UU.,
Claire y yo no hablamos sobre nuestro pasado.
En 2006,
después de 12 años
separada de mi familia,
y 7 años después de saber que estaban muertos
y ellos pensando que estábamos muertas,
nos reunimos...
del modo estadounidense más dramático posible.
En vivo,
en TV...
(Risas)
en "El Show de Oprah".
(Aplausos)
se lo dije, se lo dije.
(Risas)
Pero después del show,
al pasar tiempo con mi mamá y mi papá
y mi hermanita
y mis dos nuevos hermanos a los que nunca había conocido,
sentí rabia.
Sentí cada dolor profundo en mí.
Y yo sé que no hay absolutamente nada,
nada,
que podría devolvernos el tiempo que perdimos
y la relación que podríamos haber tenido.
Pronto, mis padres se mudaron a EE.UU.,
pero al igual que Claire,
ellos no hablan de nuestro pasado.
Ellos viven en un presente interminable.
Sin hacer demasiadas preguntas,
sin permitirse sentir...
moviéndose a pasos pequeños.
Ninguno de nosotros, por supuesto, entendió lo que nos ocurrió.
Aunque mi familia está viva...
sí, estábamos deshechos,
y sí, estamos paralizados
y fuimos silenciados por nuestra propia experiencia.
No es solo mi familia.
Ruanda no es el único país
donde las personas se han vuelto contra sí mismas,
y se han asesinado los unos a los otros.
Toda la especie humana,
de muchas maneras,
está como mi familia.
No muerta;
sí, rota, entumecida y silenciada por la violencia del mundo
que ha tomado el control.
Ya ven,
el caos de la violencia continúa
en las palabras que usamos
y en las historias que creamos todos y cada día.
Pero también en las etiquetas que nos autoimponemos y que
imponemos a los demás.
Una vez que llamamos a alguien "otro",
"menos que",
"uno de ellos"
o "mejor que",
créanme...
bajo las condiciones adecuadas,
esto es un camino corto hacia una mayor destrucción.
Más caos
y más ruido
que no vamos a entender.
Las palabras nunca serán suficientes
para cuantificar y calificar la magnitud
de todas las destrucciones causadas por el hombre.
Para que podamos
detener la continua violencia en el mundo,
espero
--al menos les ruego--
pararse.
Preguntémonos:
¿Quiénes somos sin las palabras?
¿Quiénes somos sin las etiquetas?
¿Quiénes somos dentro de cada aliento?
¿Quiénes somos dentro de cada latido?
(Aplausos)